お願いします で 今日の話は弱い心についての話です
で もしかすると皆様ご存知だと思いますけどね
まあ強い心で頑張ろうということはあまりまあ仏教で言うことでもないんです
で とにかく弱い心についていろいろお話しさせていただきます
で 皆様は別に弱い心を持ってるわけじゃないし
ですからこのその点でそんなに役に立たない可能性もありますが
で 一応この前の話でも言ったようなことで
自分たちが指導者になっているようなつもりで
いろいろ弱い人々がね
私たちの周りにいますからね
その人々にもなんとか役に立つようにと
何か指導できるかないかということで
この話を聞いていただければ結構です
いわゆる自分の心を強くするということ
それは必要ですが 我々生きているこの社会の人々は
いくらかの良い心で生きていられるように
なんとかね 手伝ってあげることができれば
それは大変ありがたいことで
それは私にできることではないんですから
というわけで 皆様方はこれを勉強なさって
自分の周りの親しい人々に何かあったら助けてあげるようにということで考えていただきたい
じゃあ話に帰ります で
弱い心ということですからね
まず私が聞きたいのは
あなたの心は弱いですか？と
という質問なんですね
で あなたの心は弱いですか？と私は聞いたら
まあ私の仏教の立場からの答えっていうのは
誰の心でも弱いですと
それは特別にあなたの心というわけではなくて
どなたの心でも結局は弱いと
それは人間に限らず どんな生命の心もものすごく弱いです
で 仏教でこういうふうなストーリーがあるんです
であの人間の心が弱いんだから
人間っていうのはまあいろいろものに頼ったりするんですね
特にいろいろお祈りしたり
あるいはいろんな神々に供え物やらね
まあいろんなことをしたりするんですね
呪文を唱えたり 奉仕をしたりとかね
いろいろ神々とかそういうものに
それも心が弱いんだから
何か守ってくださいと
助けてくださいという気持ちでやってるんですね
というわけで まあたとえ自分の心の中にお守り一つあるならば
それは何の象徴するかということは
それは心が弱いということなんです
まあそういうわけで 人類はそれだったら誰でも弱いんです
特別な問題ではないんです
お守りぐらい持ってないという人々はだいたいは少ない
でお祈りぐらいしない人っていうのは
ほとんど人類の中で少ない
隠れてでもやると 何も信じていないという人にしても
探れば何かあるんです
何かに頼っているということ
ないはずがないんです
ですから 基本的に覚えていただきたいのは
そんなに大変珍しい問題ではなくて
ただ心っていうのは弱いものですよと
それはまず理解ではなくて
覚えておいてください
で この仏教のストーリーなんですけど
でお釈迦様がそういうふうにいろんな神々にお祈りすることを見られますから
それにちょっとしたこれをお釈迦様がおっしゃったかどうか
ちょっとわかりにくいんだけど
一応経典にはあるんですね
ストーリーはこういうストーリーなんです
このシュラとアシュラ
アシュラというね 種類がいるんですね
大体日本語で阿修羅という言葉よく聞かれていますからね
まあシュラっていうのは神々
阿修羅っていうのはそちらの反対側
何者かちょっとわからないんです
だからシュラ神であるならば
その そちらの否定形はアスラなんですね
神と神でね 神ではないという存在なんですね
だから私も何者かあまりわかりませんだけど
その両方がまあたまたま喧嘩するんだと
戦うんだと それはだいたいこのインドの世界から
ヒンドゥーの世界から出てきた神話なんですがね
概念はね 仏教では阿修羅というのは
ある地獄に入れてるんですね
ある地獄の次元を説明する場合は
阿修羅界とも言葉を入れてるんですね
だから言葉は借りてるんだけど
それはヒンドゥ教で言ってる阿修羅かどうか
それまだわからないんです
シュラっていうのは神で
まあ阿修羅っていうのはもう否定形
なんか言葉ないんですね
その2人  2つ  2人がケンカすると
ケンカすると神々の王様は帝釈天なんですね
まあインドですか インドという言葉はまたバラモン教で
ヒンドゥー教で出てくる言葉で
その神様 王様で戦争に行くんですね
まあいろいろ神々連れて行って
それでこう言うんだそうです
戦闘で神々に自分の軍隊に言うんですね
あなた方はもし怖くなったら私の車の旗を見なさいと
そうすると怖くならないんだと
もし私の車の旗を見ないならば
ワルナというまた偉い神なんですね
ワルナ神の車の旗を見なさいと
そういうふうに4人の神がいるんです
で パジャッペティ神とワルナ神と
まあまあ思い出せませんだけど
その4人のもうどちらかの見える車の旗を見なさいと
で 理屈はわかります  先頭に立ってる人の旗がまだ上がっているならば
まだまだ大丈夫だということはいくらかわかりますけどね
もう戦ってもいいんだと
お釈迦様が言うのは そんなインドラ神の旗を見ても
ワルナ神の旗を見ても
あの神様怖いんだと 恐怖感はそれで消えませんと
そう見てもみんな恐怖感でもう体震えるんだと
恐怖感消えません で それ弱いということでね
それでまあキャンセル的に言っているのは
そんなものに頼ったって意味がないということなんです
お釈迦様こう言うんです
この神の王様が私の旗を見なさいと偉そうに言うんだけど
本人も怖いでしょうと
戦争に行く人々が司令官とかなんとかすごい怖いでしょう
本人も 自分も怖くて どうやって軍隊にあんた方はしっかり頑張りなさい
勇気を出して戦いなさいとかね
そんなことを言うだけで
本人はどうですか 一番自分を守って隠れているんです
それで言い訳もするんですね
私が死んじゃったら誰がもう指令出すんですかと
計画立てたりしてね ああだこうだとか
あのも全部嘘なんです
結局本人も怖いんです
ですから自分も怖くてね
人の怖さをなくすということはできないんだと
なぜ怖いかというと その神々はまあ
老婆がね むさぼりがあって
怒りがあって 無知があるんだと
だから貪瞋痴ですね 老後と怒りと貪りとあると
どうせ誰でも怖いんだと
誰でも弱いんだと だから助けにはならないんだと
それで言ってるのは まあ我々はいろんなものに頼っては
なんか心を慰めてはいるんです
大丈夫だと でもそれで大丈夫じゃないんです
じゃあいろんなありったけのお守りなんかね
体にもうぶら下がってね
ポケットやらカバンやらあっちこっちもう入れてみてください
それでもう心の弱みとかね
なくなってすごい自信がつきますかと
つかないんですよ 本当は
ただ一時的に自分には大丈夫だと水分感じかけておけば
まあいくらかはまあもうの時間は持てますけどね
それでも失敗しちゃったらすぐあれは消えちゃうんですね
で もう頼りませんと そこであの経典で言ってる答えは
人は弱いっていうことを認めているんですね
ですから やっぱり助けは必要だと
それだったらしっかりと何ものにも怖がらない
何ものにもビクッとしない
動揺しない 心を持ってるブッダに頼ってみたらどうですか
理由はお釈迦様にはブッダには貪瞋痴はないんだと
怖がるのは貪瞋痴あるんだからなんです
欲があると怖くなる 怒りがあると怖くなる
無知な人は怖くなる  3つもないんだと
そうすると確実に恐怖感がなくなるんだと
その経典は一般の方々に言ってることではなくて
大体この森の中に入って修行するお坊さんたちのために言ってるんですね
森の中で一人でずっと瞑想すると
もうかなり恐怖感に追われちゃうんです
心をいろいろ感情ができたりするんだから
その恐怖感が出てくると
あ どうしようかと 修行を途中でやめて逃げたくもなります
人がいっぱいいるところに逃げたくなるんですね
それで言うのは心配するなと
私を信じなさいと 私がちゃんとこの修行をやって
こういうふうな状態になっているんだから大丈夫ということなんです
ですから 仏法僧に頼って寄与して信じて修行すれば
まあたまたま出てくる恐怖感とかなんとかとか
全部なくなってしまうんだと
大体はまあ仏法僧に 特に例えばお釈迦様がおっしゃっている真理とかね
それをきちんと理解しておけば
もう世の中で何も怖いものはなくなっちゃうんです
それほど厳密に合理的に具体的に真理誰も語ってないんだから
まあそういうことで まあそこら辺は後で話の後で説明いたします
で 人間の心は誰の心でも弱いと
貪瞋痴ある限りは弱いとと覚えておいていただきたい
弱くないのは悟った人だけなんです
そういうわけで 誰でも弱いということにします
じゃあ ということで 我々には一つ理解できることがあるんです
弱いのは当たり前のことだから
決してそれは一般的に言うと
俗的な俗的なレベルで言うと
心が弱いっていうのは決して問題ではありません
ある人はすごい心が弱いと
決して問題ではありません
それは心が弱いこと 別に何か悪いわけじゃないんです
誰でも一般的だから どんな生命でも悟ってない人は心弱い
だから何ですか？ということなんですね
問題ないと だからノーマルですか
ノーマルな普通の人々は心が弱い
それは決して悪いわけじゃないんです
もう何とかしてそれを直せばよろしいことで
あまり問題にしてはいけないんです
世の中を見ると 何か人々がこの弱い心をなんとかして頑張るようにしてあげようとかね
怠け心を叩き直してあげようとか
なんと根性 何て言いますか
根性を直して何とかしようとかやってますけど
あれが問題なんです 何やってるんですか？その人の根性を叩き直そうと言ってる人々の根性はどうですかね
ちょっとしたことでもう尻尾を巻いて逃げるんだから腰を上げるんだから
ただ自分より弱い人々を励まして偉そうなことを言ってるだけなんです
まあ例えばね 弱い人々をなんとかしっかりせんかとね
聞いて厳しく言う人々は
自分の周りの人々は自分よりは弱いんですね
自分よりは だから偉そうに言うだけで
結局は弱い者いじめじゃないかなと私も思いますけど
わかりやすく言えば 例えば学校の先生たちがね
しっかりしないかとか
あと塾とかね なんかもう戦争するような感じでね
子供たちにすごいことを言うんだけど
それ言ってる本人はどうですかと
自分が自分のなんかすごい試験とかなんとかったら
それでも自分がどうですかと
自分の気持ちがビクビクしてないんですかね
神経質にならないんですかね
それだったら子供たちに言ってもいいんです
しっかりしなさいと 私なんかどんな試験があっても全然緊張しなかったんですよと
そんなことないのに まあ子供たちは弱いの当たり前ですからね
それは認めてあげないで
ただあれはいじめなんです
ですから 弱いはいいんです
別に しっかり必要ないんです
だからテーマと反対なのよ
この結論が で なんで弱いのはいいかというと
ちゃんとした理性ある人々
ちゃんと物事を見れる人々はだいたい弱みを感じるんです
わかりやすいけば 例えば個人が人がいる
その人は子供でもいいし
大人でもいいし いろんなことをしなくちゃいけない
子供だったら勉強したり
試験を受けたりとかしなくちゃいけないし
大人はちゃんと仕事をしたりしなくちゃいけないし
それでその人にとっては一応正しい知識あるならば
正しく世の中見えるならば
怖くなるはずなんです
なぜならば たとえ試験に勉強にしたっても
これすごい難しい世界でしょうに
大変な世界なんです そんな簡単に甘くうまくいくわけじゃないんです
仕事にしたっても もう簡単にうまく何のことなくいくわけじゃないんです
いっぱいライバルがいるんです
商売になったっても 自分が何か新しい製品開発しましたよと言ったっても
もう二 三週間で他の人もっといいものを開発しちゃうし
ですから 自分の頭がすごくいいんだと悪い子供たちが思ったっても
ちょっと周り見ればもっと頭がいい人々は結構いるんです
例えば競争的な試験もありますね
何人か選べるとかね 会社とかその場合とかね
あるいは公務員の試験とか
その場合はもう競争だから何人か選べるということ
それで一人の人が じゃあ私はもう結構勉強できたんだから
頭良かったんだから大丈夫だと思ったっても
本当に正気で物事を考えちゃうと
結構もっと頭のいい人々は見つかるんです
そうすると不安になるんです
ですから 世の中を見ると不安になるのは普通なんです
当たり前なんです それから自分の能力を見ると
それは客観的な見方なんですけど
で 例えば頭がいい人々がね
すごく知識がある 頭がいい人々が自分の能力を判断してみる
自分に何ができるか 何ができないかとかね
どれぐらいできるかとか
勉強はしたんだけど 本当に知識があるかないかとかね
本当に物事をわかっているかないかとか
そういうふうに主観的に自分のことを考えてみると
だいたいそんな大したことないと発見できるんです
自分の能力の で それでまた自信が消えちゃうんです
例えば 人々が自信があるんだ
体力あるんだ 頭はいいんだとか
健康的だとか美しいんだとかね
そういう私は綺麗だとかね
そういうことでもすごい自信ついてはいますけど
でも本気になって考えちゃうと
自分が本当に美しいかといえば
もっと美しい人々は見えるはずでしょうし
そんな大したことないとわかるでしょうし
私は知識人だと思ったっても
本当に自分の知識を見てみると
ああ まあどうったことないと正しく見る人には見える
それでやっぱり不安だと
やっぱり心配だと感じるはずなんです
そういうわけで 私は言いたいのは
心は何も問題なく 一般的で合理的に知識的に活動しているならば
どなたでも不安を感じるはずなんです
それは決して間違っていることでも
いけないことでもないんです
ですから 不安を感じるならば
心は弱いと感じるならば
健康的ということなんです
精神的には その困る必要ないんです
いろいろ不安があるんだとわかったら
まあ健康的ですよと 精神的には問題ないんだと
覚えておけばよろしいです
じゃあ逆に考えちゃうとね
世の中を見ると心が全然弱くない人々もいるんですね
そういうふうに不安を感じない
全然弱くない 心は見る限りにはものすごく活動するはもう明るくいろんなことをやっているように見えると
その人々はどういうことでしょうかと
で  私たちの仏教の立場から言えば
すごく全然弱い気持ちも全くなく
不安もなく 堂々と頑張っている人々はどこかでおかしいんです
精神的には健康的だとはちょっと言いにくいんです
なぜかというと そういう自信満々の人々のことを観察してみてください
まず怖いものを知らないというか
結果がわからないというか
とにかくやってみようということだけなんですね
だから何だかんだでも
じゃあ行動してみよう
やってみようと言っても
これ無知じゃないかと
いわゆる判断能力ないと
ということなんです 本当は
過剰自信？なんです 何でもやる人々は
もう悩んだり くよくよしたり
何もしない よし やりましょうと
すぐ行動に出るんですね
あれはもう過剰自信で判断能力なくて
もう無知なんです そこで
そういう人々のもう一つの特色があるんです
やりますと思ったら この結果がありますね
あ こうなりたいと 例えばもう金儲けたいと
金持ちになりたいと ただ金持ちになりたいということしか頭にないんです
それ金持ちになった状態は別に悪い状態じゃないんだけど
その妄想で頭がいっぱいで
何も見えないんですね
だからもう行動するんです
そういうのはただ夢だけやって
夢を目指して頑張ることだけだから
知識的とは言えないんです
で 欲だけあってね 大体この何かしたいとか
何かになりたい 偉くなりたい
社会的なね 立場やら位置やら何か得たいとかね
名誉やら財産やら得たいとか
知識とかなんとか得たいとか
何かすごい欲があって
強力な その欲でもう目に膜を張るんです
何も見えないようにする
して その目的を見て頑張るんです
ですから 方法は簡単です
すごい心は強くて もう勇気を持っても
一歩通行で行動したければバカになればいいんです
何も外は見ないと 一つだけ見て
もう 夜歩くことそのことだけ
日本では難しいんだけど
暗闇で歩く時は僕らは結構経験があります
足元は見えないんです
足元を見ると歩けないんです
夜だから 暗闇だから そこで方法はどこかの光を見るんです
遠く それ光を見て上を向いて歩けばいいんです
歩けるんです 歩けるのは歩けるんだけど
そこで穴があったらそれでも落ちるし
ヘビがいたらもう踏んだところで噛まれるし
その危険はないわけないんです
日本で私は茨城の方にいた時は
もう山の中で全く明かりはもうどこにもないんです
街灯もない だから夜行かなく違いないんです
まるっきり光の一欠片もないんです
その上 道路っていうのはもう穴だらけで
もう泥いっぱい あっちこっち歩けないんです
何をするんですか？空を見るんですね
空を見ると周りはずーっと木でもう隠れてるんだけど
道路ありますから そこら辺ずっとほんのちょっと線だけ空は見えるんです
その空を見て歩くんです
そこで知らないうちにボーンとこの
泥の中に落ちたりとか
もういろいろもうもう膝の下からはもうもう希望なし
何も で それでやっと行けるんです
ですから 行動したければ
まあそういう風にもう周りを見ないようにすれば行動にはなるんです
そういうわけで まあ結論で言うならば
弱い方がいいということになるんです
心は弱い方がいいと で
で 健康って まあ私はちょっとあの形容詞を作りたい使いたいんだけど
健康的な弱さなんですね
いわゆる精神的な健康というかね
健全というか 言葉あまりわかりませんだけど
まあ精神的には普通でノーマルで健康的で
その人の弱みというのは決して悪いことではないんです
それ特典になるんです
それに健康的な弱い心を持つことでいろいろ得があるんです
一つはその人は物事を見ているんだだから自分の能力も計算して弱みが生まれたんだから
外の世界を見たところで弱みが生まれたんだから慎重なんです
物事を 物事を慎重に判断して行動するんです
それは決して悪いことじゃないんですね
そこで誰でも何か結果が考えて行動するんですね
で それで結果だけ見て
それを目指して行くぞと
暗闇で光 どこか微かな光見て
もうどうでもいいと もう牛の上でも虎の上でも歩いていくということはもうないんです
いつでも状況とか判断するんですね
一歩ずつ一歩ずつ判断しながら
自分の道をいつでも調整しながら
その弱い人々が行動するのです
それから その人々にだけもう一つ特典があります
工夫ということ 自分の弱みを知っている
その自分目指している結果が得られるかないかという社会の状況も
いわゆる主観的・客観的に物事を見ているんですね
例えば商売成功しようと思ったっても
自分の努力だけでは努力だけでは成功するわけじゃないし
社会の経済状況もそれなりにまとめてないとうまくいかないものだから
ですから 主観的にも客観的にも物事を判断する
で 判断すると あ どうすればよろしいかと
この場合はどうすればいいんですかと
この障害を乗り越えるためにはどうすればいいかともう工夫が思い浮かぶんですね
ひらめくんですね ですから
それは大変ありがたいことなんです
弱さ認めない人にとっては
その工夫とか何もないんです
ただやるだけ そういうことで
弱みの特典というのは
工夫がよくひらめくこと
それから そういう人は失敗したらどうするんですかね
心は自分で弱いということをわかって行動はするんだけど
失敗したんだと それで全然落ち込まないんですね
落ち込む必要ないんだから
別に知ってるんだから
努力したってもそんな甘くはないんだと
世の中は知ってるし だから失敗したっても全然落ち込まない
それはすごいありがたいことなんです
ですから そういう人々がそういう不安あるながらも
弱みがありながらも 物事を判断しながら
なんとか前へ前へ進んで行動はする
間違いながらも そこで落ち込むこともないし
そこで成功したんだからといって
俺がやったぞとは思わない
私がやったら必ず成功するぞという過剰自信もない
やっと成功しましたという気持ちで終わっちゃうんです
それで落ち着きがあるんですね
そういう特典があるのは
この心が健康的な人々の心っていうのは弱いということをわかっている時なんですね
そういうわけで やっぱりまあ弱い方が安全なんですね
じゃあ 心強く 心弱くない人々
堂々と行動する行動派の人々
世の中 いつでもリーダーシップ取りたがる人々
その人々にはどんな特典
どんな欠点かといえば
まあ私に見えるのは悪いかもしれませんだけど
欠点だけなんです このすごいリーダーシップを持って
みんな引っ張って行動する人々の間ではね
まあ大体いろんな人々の行動を見て考えてね
もういろんな人々 出家の人だからね
いろんな人に会ったり話したりする機会もあるしね
だからやっぱりそういうあんまり行動派の人々の中では
欠点いっぱい見えるんです
で もうここら辺 いちいち説明しなくても皆さんわかると思いますけどね
そういう人々は何かはもうもう元気で頑張るではないかとは行動はするんですが
それは自分のためになるか
社会のためになるか 全然気にしないんです
自分がそれで損するか
他人がそれで損するか
他人に迷惑をかけるか
それは気にしない 全くそんなことを構わず
もう行動だけ それでいいんですかね
あまりにももう張り切りすぎの人々がいると
かなり迷惑じゃないですか
そこでそういう人々はとにかく自分の行動によって
あるいは自分 例えば自分目指した結果でも
それはいいか悪いかもう考えないんですね
自分が何をやってるかとか考えない
人を集めて行動しなくては
とにかく強引にでも集めてもらう
集めた人々にそれで迷惑かどうか
それは気にしない まあ社会を見てください
随分元気で行動する人々はどれほど他人に迷惑をかけているかと
そこでそういう迷惑をかけてもよく見えることは気にしない
まあ行動だけ頭にしか他のことないんだからね
そういうことで言えるのは
そういうこの行動主義
心は強すぎというか 心は強いとくよくよしないと思っている人々は
結局社会に迷惑をかけているんです
かなりの迷惑をかけているんです
それで そういう人々に限ってすごい独裁的なんですね
独善的なんですね それでまた見える特色があります
そういうすごく活動する人々は
あまり人の話は聞かない
私はこの よく知っている人々がね
まあ昔もいましたけど
もう私なんか怖くて何も行動にはいけない
いけないんだけど で 私と比べたらもう何も力もないし
また 1%でも でも大胆な行動もすぐ始まるんですね
始まったら 私はたまたま知ってる友達だからね
まあまあ他の人のいろんな批判もありますからね
そういうふうにいろいろ意見はありますけどって言ったら
で 私には黙ってて この自分仕事をさせてる人々には人の言うことを聞くなと
こういうふうにやれと
ただそれだけ で 人の話聞かないんですね
なんで聞かないかとかわかってます
私も前も言ったんだから
この大胆に強い心で行動する人々は無知ですから
頭が結局悪いんですから
病気だから理解できないんです
人いうことは こんなことやったらこういう危ないところありますって言っても
そんなことわかるんだったらやらないでしょうし
ただのただ邪魔しているんだと
ただ自分の行動に嫉妬している
これにもうこの人邪魔してるだけですよということになるんですね
だから人の意見聞かない
聞いても理解できない
聞いて頭に入ったっても
それでなんとか自分の道を調整しようと
それ不可能 そういうすごい迷惑なところはあるんです
それでまあ それに反論もあるかもしれません
私は今言った考え方に
で どういう反論かというと
とにかくその行動する人々はまあ成功するんじゃないかなと
まあ確率的に言えば 例えばあの
あまりにも不安で行動しない人々よりは
なんとかもう大胆ででもいいんだから
行動する人々の中では成功する確率は高いかもしれません
でも私が言いたいのは
そんな成功も大したことないと
あまり気にせんでもいいんだと
すごい元気で行動してね
成功しましたとかね 言ってもまあそうと
まあ別に気にしないと
まあ具体的な例があるとすごいたくさんなるんです
そこで言いたいのは 因縁法則も道も何も知らないで
方法について手段についてまるっきり無関心で手段選ばず行動して成功しましたと
それはまずもう大したことはない
成功したならば言えるのは運が良かったと
ただそれだけ 暗闇の中で遠い光を見て歩いたところで
やっと目的に行ったならば
ヘビに噛まれたのは運が良かったと
噛まれた 噛まれなかったのは
崖に落ちて怪我したしなかったのは
もうただ運が良かったと
それしか言えないんです
決して合理的な道ではないんだから
そこで じゃあまた問題が起こるんです
じゃあ運が良かったと
だから じゃあ我々もバカみたいに行動すればいいんですかと
運が良ければ成功する
運が悪ければもう失敗するとということになったらどうなるかというと
あんな考え方は何の役にも立たないんですね
運がいい 運が悪いということはどうしようもないことだから
それでも問題の答えにならないんです
ということは どういうことかというと
じゃああなたの運がいいんだから頑張ってくださいととは言えますけど
じゃあ運が悪い人の場合は
あんたの運が悪いんだから
もう何もしないで待っていてくださいってことでしょうし
だから心はもう正しく導く
導いてほしければ 運が悪かろうがよかろうが
もう何か答えなければね
誰にでも通用する ですから
この運がいいということは
もうとんでもない言葉なんです
運がいいんだから成功するんですけど
それは何の役にも立たないことなんですね
ですからね 運が悪い人はどうすればいいかということも出てきますからね
そこでまた私は具体的に社会を観察したところで
見えたのは 見えた いくつかあるんですね
この運が良くて成功したんだという人々
見たら色々こと見えるんですね
そういう人々はあまりにも強引に他人を引っ張って
あまりに強引もいろんなことをやるんだから
どんな行動にしたっても
他の人々の助け関係なければ成り立たないんです
まあ一人だけでやると木登りぐらいかな
山を歩くことでも いろいろ道具やらいろんなものを使わなくちゃいけないんだからね
やっぱり人の助けは必要なんです
自分一人でやるならば
まあ木登りぐらいは成功するかもしれません
登れなくたっても やってみるぞと
といったっても滑って怪我するんですけどね
それでも怪我しないで登れたならば
運が良かったと それしか言うようがないんです
で 他の人々 他の我々 行動というのは
勉強することやら 仕事することやらね
家庭の面倒を見ることやら
もうそういう社会的なこと
そういうものだから それ全てが人間関係関わっているんですね
他人の協力なしに成り立たないんです
それでこの行動派の無知な人々が何でもやって成功するんだけど
よくよく見ると周りの人々はいろんなことで助けてあげてるんです
放っておけないと まずそれは自分の家族の一人がもう大バカもんで
何でもやるんだったら
思ったものはやると それは家族の一人ですよと言ったら
家族はどうしますかね
やっぱり家族だから心配でしょうがないんですね
だから なんとかそのバカもんが考えたことは成功できるようにいろいろ助けてあげる
いろいろ助けてあげる
あるいはその人が友達だったら
知人だったら 友人だったら
やっぱり放っておけないんですね
だから助けてあげる 助けてあげる人々には全部物事見える
見えるんだからもううまくいくんです
そこでやった人が俺がやったぞと
またすごい誤解する あるいは例えば会社ですという場合は
会社作ったんだと 作ったも何もわからない
もう頭の悪い人だと それで会社にまた他の人を雇わなくちゃいけないでしょうに
それで雇われた人々はもう雇われたんだから黙っているわけにいきませんし
ですから なんとかして自分仕事をすると会社がうまくいくようにする
それで社長が祈ると そういう風になっているんです
で あるいは何か専門的な仕事だったら
まあこういうことをやりましょうと
じゃあ飛行機作りましょうと
プラチモデルも組み立てない人が考えたら考えて会社作ったならば
その人は色々専門家が雇わなくちゃいけないんですね
自分ではプラモデルも組み立てない
じゃあやっぱり飛行機作ろうと思っちゃったらね
しょうがないんだ そこで専門家が雇ったならば
専門家には専門としてプライドがあるんですね
それで失敗したら その人にとってはすごい大変なことだから
ですから エンジニアたちエンジニアたちが飛行機設計をして作ったところで
それで事故を起こしちゃってみんな死んじゃったと言えば
エンジニアたちにとってはそれとんでもないことなんですね
ですから その専門家たちを雇ったならば
その人々は真剣 真面目に自分のプライドがありますから
自分の専門分野だからちゃんとやるんです
だから病院作ろうと思ったら
もうどんな人にもできます
お金ぐらいあれば でもそれにはちゃんとした医者やら看護婦さんやら
そういう経営者やら雇っておけば
お医者さんはいくらなんでも患者さんを殺すわけにいきませんだから真剣にやってあげる
それでもうまく経営うまくいっちゃうと
この人がどうですかね
私の行動はと言われるだけ
ですから このただ行動ばっかりやっている人々は
結局は成功する場合は
それも周りの人々がよく頑張ってくれたからなんです
私はある人に知ってる
自分の名前もそこにサインできないんです
でも億万長者にで商売やってすごい金持ちなんです
ただその本人にあるのは欲だけ
金儲かりたい それでいろんな人に行って頼んで頼んで
あんたこれやってください
お願いします とかね 言われると
この頼まれた側はなんか運が良くて
みんなそれなりのプロなんですね
物事知ってる人々なんですね
そこで失敗しちゃったら自分に悪いんだからね
自分が失敗したことになると
その人ではなくて そこでちゃんとやっちゃうんです
いわゆるこのエクスポート関係
なんて言いますか 輸入関係の仕事してるんだけど
英語やらいろんなこと必要でしょうね
英語のところはサインもやっと後で勉強したんです
だからよくやるなと思います
だからなんでよくやるやるんですか？というと
あまりにも頭が悪いんだからなんです
あまりにも頭が悪いんだから
ずいぶん元気で行動する
そこで周りの人にまあもういろいろお願いして歩き回るんだから
みんなまあしょうがないと
自分にできることだからやってあげようと
そこでもしその周りの人々がね
ちょっとでも まあなんでこの人のためにこんなやらなくちゃいけないかなと思った瞬間で
全部もう倒れちゃいます
たまたまそういうこと見えるでしょういいね
あんまりもう 社長やら課長やらあんまりにもひどくて
もう自分が辞めるよと
辞めたところで会社も終わりと
社長が自分で作った会社だったら何人か辞めたらどうぞ辞めてください
私は一人でもやりますよと
私に能力あるよということになりますけどね
そうはないんです ですから私が言いたいのは
その そういうふうにね
ものあまりにも頭が悪くて
あまりにも物事を見えない人が
人々がずっと頑張って行動して
世の中ですごい成功したっても
私たちの勉強にはならないんです
何の勉強にもならないんです
だから放っておけばいいんです
そういうものは もし行動派の人々が成功したなと思ったら
じゃあ私もやるぞと 怖いもの知らない感じで行動するぞと思わない方がいいんです
勉強にならない ただ誰かに助けてくれただけ
逆にいろんな人々が助けてくれるんだから
じゃあなんとかやりましょうというのは
それは逆なんです それは別に問題ないんです
私の私一人にできるわけじゃない
こういうこういう友達がいて
こういう兄弟がいて こういう家族がいて
で だからこういうことできるんだから
まあやりましょうという場合は
本人はそれをちゃんと状況判断しているんだからね
そういうことでは別に問題ないんだけどね
ですから このあまりこの私はこの行動的な心が強いと
強気の人々の成功はちょっとあのケチをつけたいんですね
強気にはそんなに立派なものじゃないんだと
で あの じゃあそれで問題解決するかというとね
まあまあ一応そこら辺で一旦一旦ね
ポイントを終えて じゃあみんな心は弱いという立場に戻りますけど
じゃあみんな心が弱くて
あまりにも心配がいろいろあって
不満があって もう何もできない状態にいると
やっぱりそれも良くないんですね
なんとかその弱い心をなんとか行動できるように
もうちょっと工夫しなくちゃいけないんですね
調整しなくちゃいけない
だからといって この物事は不安だよということを忘れてはいけません
不安は不安ですけど だからといってじっと待ってるわけじゃないんです
その不安な心をどうやって乗り越えられるかと
そこはまあ いくらか私たち考えなくちゃいけないところなんですね
ですから 一番簡単な早い方法はお守りする
お守りを買うことなんです
お守りを買ったら これさえあれば大丈夫だと
そこであの不安 だから私もね
仏学の分 仏教の立場から喋ってますから
どうせ一般常識とはね
いろいろずれてるところはあるかもしれませんだけど
私が言いたいのはこの不安でいいんだと
心配でよろしいと それ不安と心配ということはうまく使う
なぜ不安が生まれたかと
客観的に見ればいいんです
あ こういうこういうわけで
これは問題だと 今会社が始まっても経済状態は良くないんだと
だから不安だと そういう風にこの
ちゃんと知った方がよろしいんですね
問題は そう知ると 自分が何か目的ある
その目的を達成しようと思っても
自分にはそれほど能力はない
この目的は社会の関わりで
人間関係で達成するものだから
気乗りじゃないんだから
ですから この人々の関係も社会状況も計算に入らなくちゃいけないし
入ったところで ああ これは大変だ
これはちょっとまずいんだとかね
いろんなこと見えるんです
自分の弱みも見えてくる
そうすると これはどうなるかというと
パズルができちゃうんですね
何のことなく生きるということは
一つのパズルであると
会社作って成功しますよ
と思っても 不安な人にとっては
それはいとも簡単にやるぞということではなくて
あ これ大変なパズルだよと
このパズルということは
コンピューターでひらがなで出る
もうカタカナで出るか出るかと思って打ってみたのに出てこなかったんです
だからどんな風に書くか分からないにカタカナになると
英語ではパズルというんですね
パズルって言ってますね
ご存知です 僕は英語の発音しますけどね
で 一つ一つ我々に毎日パズルが出てきちゃうんですね
心は健康な人には これパズルが出てきたら
邪魔なものいっぱいあるのは当たり前なんですね
例えば何て言いますか
このジグソーパズルありますね
ジグソーパズルにしたっても
もうバラバラもう壊れてるんだから
ピースが それで一個一個ピース見たってもさっぱりわからないと
じゃあそれでゆっくりとコツコツジグソーパズルだったらまあどうしようもない
わからないんだから まあとにかく
あの 何て言いますか コーナーピース 4つありますからね
じゃあコーナーピース 4つでも調べましょうと
それでコーナーピースを調べたりする
それでもわからない これ右上か左下かまたわからない
それだったら次に出てくるのは
じゃあ全てのコーナーを探してみようと
全てのコーナーを探してつなげてつなげてみると
ああ なんとかもう出来上がってくるんです
そこで似ている色で見るとかね
形で見るとか それから元の絵を見たら一番わかりやすいところを先にやるとかね
そういう風に人間は行動するべきなんですね
だから引っかかるとこあります
止まるとこあります ずーっとなんかこのもうダムが破れたような感じで
ダムが破れちゃった 水がずっとこう
そんな感じで行動できるわけじゃないんです
止まったり たまたま調子が良くて
すぐすぐパズルのピースが見つかったりとかね
たまたまこういうこともありますね
他のピースは見つかっちゃうと
1つのピースが随分目に入っちゃう
あ これはこういう場所のピースだよと知ってるんです
それで あ これはすぐ見つかるんだと思ってそこに置いとくんだけど
そこら辺になってくると
あれ見つからないとかね
そういうふうなことを人生なんです
ですから 不安で止まることは意味がない
無知で強気で行動することはもう全く危ないし
それどっちでも取らないで
パズルで迷路で取っちゃうんです
これ迷路だと 迷路を通して見ちゃったら一歩一歩進めるし
進めるたびにすごい気持ちいいんです
成功とかなんとか考えないんですね
とにかくもうこれまでできたっていうことで大変気持ちいいんですね
それは人間の心 生きる場合はね
そのような心を作ればよろしいんじゃないかなと
で そこまで喋ったのは
なんかちょっとポイント
あのちょっとまた戻ります
あの僕はちょっと言いたいことが一つありまして
この忘れちゃったんです
あの この強気の人々の欠点言うところなんです
言ったところなんですけど
強気の人々の欠点というのはね
みんなに迷惑をかけるとかね
まあああだこうだと言ったし
まあ成功したっても大した大したことでもないと言ったしに
強気の人々は失敗したらどうなるかと言い忘れちゃったんです
私がやったらもう成功するぞとかなんとかって
すごい強気でやって じゃあ失敗したらどうなるんですかね
その人は失敗 だから弱い人は別に失敗したっても気にしないんだから
強い人は逆なんです 失敗したらとことん落ち込むんです
そんなはずではなかったと
そういうのはもの強気なんです
よく言うんですね そんなはずではなかったと
あなた神様ですかねと私が聞きたいんです
自分でこうすればこうなりますよと決める権利あるわけないでしょうに
宇宙全ての生命創造した神様だったらね
いえ そんなはずではないと言ったっても構いませんだけど
でも強気な人はいつでもそう言うんです
そんなはずではなかったと
このそんなはずではなかったというのは
もう随分落ち込んでるということなんです
すごく落ち込む あるいはもう一つあります
その人々が この強気の人々が失敗しちゃったら
落ち込むか怒りで爆発するんです
自分がもう何か目的あって
他のことを何も見ないでやろうとしたところでできなかったと怒りで爆発する
どうするかわからない
他人に叱るはあなたのせいではないかとかね
ああだこうだとかね 誰かのせいにしちゃうんですね
あれ何やるか あるいは全く全部壊してしまう可能性もあります
この政治の世界で見られた見られると思いますね
例えばこのいろんな政治家が出てきて
まあ強気で独裁的でやろうとする
それで国民がいろいろ反対したりすると
ものすごく人殺したり
いろんなことをやったりするでしょうね
この世の中でそういう国々があるでしょう
今もインドネシア大統領が逃げちゃったりしているんだからね
ずっと汚いことをやっていて
バレるようになったところでも
その人逃げたんだけどね
フィリピンとかね でも平気で人を殺したりするんですね
自分がもうやりきれない
もう失敗 失敗 失敗だらけで
フィリピンの前のね マルコス大統領とかね
そういうところになったら
もう失敗っていうこと知ってるでしょうね
そうすると徹底的に独裁
徹底的にもう民主選挙はなしとか
何も全部もう軍事政権にするぞとか
それからまた秘密警察をああだこうだ作ったりして
平気でもう殺したりもするんですね
それはその例なんです
南アメリカの国々でもそういう現象はあるし
アフリカでもそうであるし
南アジアの方でも結構あるんです
だから怒りで爆発するんですね
だから独善的に独裁的になったということ自体も
もう大愚か者ということでしょうし
頭が悪いということなの
何も見えない人だから
第2次世界戦争のヒットラーにヒットラー
ヒットラーにしても同じことでしょう
うまくいかないなと思ったら
もう殺したい放題殺すになっちゃう
ですから この強気の人っていうのは
本当にもう失敗したらすごく危ないんです
どうしても行動するんだから
やる行動が良くないんですね
それは一つ言い忘れたことで
それから それは偉い人の場合なんですね
我々みたいな普通の人々の間で
そういう強気の人がいると
強気な人がいて 会社作ったり
いろんなことを活動したりする
それで失敗しましたと言ったらすごい迷惑なんですね
こうなったんだから助けてくれ
お金ちょうだい もうもう1000万
3,000万円ちょっともうもう何て言いますか
もう損しましたから もう担保になったんだからお金貸してくれとかね
なんとかしてくれ なんとかしてくれと周りにもう頼みばっかしで
これも結構迷惑で 自分勝手にいろんな投資したり
株を買ったりして それで儲からなかったら
親戚やら周りの友達やらみんなに迷惑なんですね
そこで人々っていうのはやっぱり見放すこともできないし
放っておくこともできないし
放っておいちゃったら
あなたほどの失礼な もうなんて言います
失礼というよりは あのもうね
まあきつい人でもないんです
その言葉はね なんて言いますか
人が困ってると助けるべきではないかとかね
ああだこうだとか言って周りに迷惑かける
だから政治家みたいにいろんな国々によるね
まああの人殺しに行かないかもしれませんだけど
私たちの 例えば知ってる人が誰か何かやってしまって失敗しちゃったら関係ない
周りの人々全部あの人を助けてあげなくちゃいけない
借金のね もうそれ立てるためにいろいろ援助したりしなくちゃいけない
たまたまあるでしょ 家族の息子がなんか変なことやってしまって
もうすごいもう借金になってしまったところに
親がいろいろ工夫 苦労して
苦労して それを何とかしなくちゃいけない
ですから 親にとってはもう息子だから捨てるわけにもいきませんし
捨てたっても家に家に帰ってきて
またどんな暴力振るかわからないし
あるいは盗んででも持っていくんだからね
まあいろいろ家の権利書やらなんとかあるならば
それやら印鑑やそういうものはね
盗んで持っていくんだから
だからそこはまあ迷惑と周りに
あるいは あまりにもガガツヨイ人はこのどうしますか？自殺するんです
失敗したら 認めないんで自分の失敗は
そんなはずではなかったと
自殺するかホームレスになるか
そういうふうなことなんですね
ですから この強気の人が行動して成功すれば
周りのおかげで失敗したら周りに迷惑かけるか
自分が自殺して あるいはホームレスになるとか
なんとかになるか どっちかなんですね
だから強気はよくない
じゃあそのポイントは忘れましたけど
大事なポイントだからね
まあまた戻ります じゃあまたあのパズルのお話に戻ります
ですから 正しく行動する人はちゃんと物事を判断して
人生はパズルとして見て
迷路として見て 一歩ずつ一歩ずつ組み立てていけばいいんです
たまたま止まるところもあるし
たまたま動き tooでもあるし
そんなものに別に気にしないで
まあ着々と進めば その行動一つ一つ楽しくなるんです
で それは 1つで それから世の中ではこのちょっとした弱いことが
例えばこの現代教育でもね
勝てることしか教えてないんですね
勝ちなさいと金メダル取りなさいと
ほんのわずか才能が見えちゃったら
すぐもう最高なところまでもう想像して
もう押し付けるんですね
だから小さい時 幼稚園の時からも子供たちにこの勝てることしか教えてない
だからごまかしですね
まあ幼稚園の運動会見たっても
人間一番勉強するべきなのは勝つことよりは負けることなんです
負けることを味わわないと
なぜかと 人生の中で勝つ確率よりは負ける確率の方がものすごい多いんです
毎日勝ちっぱなしの人生っていうのはありえないんです
それは決してありえない物事
世の中っていうのはもう私たちやってるものではないんだから
因果法則によるものだから
だから大体っていうのは
まあ人生はまあ失敗するのは多いし
何かやったら負ける確率はすごい多いし
それ勉強していない 例えばこのいろんな 100種類のものにチャレンジすると
成功するのは 1つだけやとすると
それでもどうやらわいわい万歳とか言うことだけ覚えてるんです
それじゃあ 99回の失敗どうしますかと
わからないですね そういうことで
正しく心を育てたければ
ものすごい厳密に負ける技と技と言えないんだけどね
負けることを負けたらどうなるかと
負けてどういうものかと
きちんと明確に理解しておかなくちゃいけないんですね
例えば運動会にしたっても
必ずしも自分が勝てるわけじゃないし
ですからそこはちゃんと
その人はこうなったんだから勝ちます
こういうふうに この自分がこういうこういうわけで
もうビリになったとかね
ちゃんと冷静な心で理解して
その状況を受け止めることができないと生きていられないんです
だから 負けることを知らない人々はもう誰も行動できないんです
それは病気になってしまうんです
それはもう社会で 現代社会でよくもうとっても見えることで
だから行動したい人はまず覚えてほしいのは
100回チャレンジしたら 99回は負けるんだと
一回ぐらいはもうもう勝てる可能性はありますと
だから 100対 1ですよと
それを理解すればもう行動できるんです
別になんのことなく だからそういうことでね
まあよくこの子供たちなんかね
自殺するのはそういう負けることを知らないんです
いじめられたら いじめられたと
じゃあ自殺するぞと あれで何にもならないんだから
別に あるいは人を殺してやるぞと
なんか言われたんだと
だからムッとしましたと
そこで刺してやるとか
なんか言われたってても
まあ別に まあそんなもんだよとね
理解する すごいもう心が育っておかないと
まあ結構大人も子供も自殺する場合はみんなこのもうもう行動派なんです
僕は悪い意味で行動派と言うんですけど
いわゆるもう本当に頭が悪い
だから行動して成功することしか見えてない
だからもう自殺 大人も自殺する
インテリの人々も自殺する
小学生も中学生ももう自殺してるし
みんなこの もしできれば
この自殺した人々のあの性格を見てください
すごい頑固であることは発見できると思います
すごい頑固で で このまたいるんで
このすごく控えめに控えめにいる人々いるんですね
例えば教室にある子供がすごい控えめにいるんだと
あれも頑固なんです だから調和しない
そのから自分も控えておく
それでいじめられたからといってもう自殺する
だからこの表面的に控えめっていうこともあまり意味がない
心の中を見なくちゃいけない
なんで控えめにしてるんですかと
なんで一歩下がってるんですかと
もしかすると負けず嫌い
だから戦わない そういうことで
世俗的な世俗的な話はもうまあそこら辺で
もうちょっと 1ポイントを言って終了しますが
あの 行動するときはまず結果を置いておく
パズルだからね 結果は置いといて
まああまり大胆に考えないで
その時のできること その時のできることだけ
一歩ずつ一歩ずつ行動を進んでいけばよろしいんですね
行動自体を喜ぶ 結果をあまり気にしないと
それからもう一つ大事なポイントあります
自分の行動自体正しいかないかと
それにチェックしてほしいんです
この結果見る人はチェックしないんです
まあ悪い例で言うならば
お金入るんだったら銀行強盗でもいいんじゃないかと
それはもう結果だけ見るとそういう風にいるんですね
だから結果はもう置いとく
置いといて 行動は正しいかないか
今やることはよろしいかないか
それをチェックするんです
結果をあんまり気にしない
そうやるとあまり他人に迷惑ないし
自分にも迷惑なく 着々と行動できるんですね
それから あ 行動がこれはこの行動は間違いだと
これは失敗だとわかったら
もうなんのことなく じゃあ直しましょうと
その自分の行動を直すこともすごく何て言いますか
楽しく感じればいいんです
喜びを感じればいいんです
この行動派の人々が人々に
あんたあんなことやったんだけど
あれは大変な良くないことでしょうとけしからんと言ったら怒るでしょうし
余計なことを言うなと
そんな恥ずかしいことをなんで言うんですかと怒るんです
で 知恵ある人が不安であることを知っている人が
どうせ自分も不安であるし
うまくいかないとね 心配もあるしそこでこの間こういうふうにことをしたんだけど
あれはちょっとダメですと
ああ そうですかね やっぱりダメですかね
じゃあやっぱりもっとしっかりしなくちゃと
その人は自分の道を直すんですね
ですから 正しい行動をする人は
そういうふうに失敗しても間違っても
それ直すことに喜びを感じると
この間こういうことをして失敗しましたから
今は私はこういうふうにやるんだよというふうに
この喜びを感じる で それからこのあまりにも心配しすぎて行動しない人々がいますね
だいたい問題になるのはそういう人々なんですけど
あまりにも物事を心配して心配してね
不安でもう何も行動しないと
その人々はやっぱりまだ病気なんですけど
あんまり結果ばっかり考えてるんですね
だから僕は結果を考えてはいけないと
結果を置いておくと 結果ばっかり考えると
これわからないんですね
いい結果が出るか出ないかと
そうすると行動できなくなるんですね
この行動 何もしないで怠ける人々の不思議なこと
完璧主義なんです 何もしない
ただ怠けてるだけ 喋ってみたらまあ理想の高いこと
ですから この怠ける人っていうのは
もうかなり理想が高い
あまりにも高すぎて何もできない
それで怠けてるんです
それもその人々の問題は結果見ている
ですから 結果を見ない
見ないではなくて 結果を気にしない
そんなにもそれを置いておく
いくらかはまあこういう結果のために頑張るということはありますからね
それで着々と一歩一歩の行動はどういうものかと
それは正しいかないかとチェックしながらやることなんですね
そういうことで いくらかの我々の
常に我々にある弱い心を生きる場合は何とか乗り越えられます
あの ちょっと今ちょっと一休みをして
で 仏教の話に入ります
どうもありがとうございます
じゃあ 2部が始まります
で 今まで喋ったのはまあ俗世間なことで
あまり私に関係あることではないんです
で これからまあ 仏教のお釈迦様のね
立場から弱い心に対していろいろ話したいと思います
で まあ仏教の立場から言えば
まあ弱い心っていうのは
世の中の人々はね あまり好ましくない
ですから もうよく聞える聞こえる言葉っていうのは
頑張れという言葉なんですね
で あんまりこの頑張れという言葉はね
仏教から言えばあまり意味がないんですね
頑張れと言えば 何に頑張って頑張らなくちゃいけないんですかと
何をするために頑張らなくちゃいけないんですかと
まあちゃんと聞いてもらわないと
で だいたい世の中で あの欲のために頑張れと言ってるんですね
勉強頑張れと 仕事を頑張れと
ああだこうだとか言ってるのは
やっぱり世間の欲的なことに頑張れということなんですね
収入を作るために頑張れと
でもなんかそういう風に頑張れと言うんです
じゃあそんな風に頑張れということは
正直なところで 仏教ではちょっと言いにくいんです
で 世の中で頑張れっていうことは
仏教から見れば言葉変えちゃうんです
苦しめという言葉になっちゃうんです
だから苦しめということなんで
人に苦しめとは言えないんです
まあ結婚頑張れとかね
頑張っていい相手見つかってくださいととは言うんだけど
仏教からは何も言えませんね
これはまあ苦しめということだからね
もう独身の人は結婚すればそれなりに新しい苦しみがたくさん増えるだけのことだから
もうせっかく結婚したんだからね
まあ子供を作るためにも頑張れとか何とか言うでしょうね
でも子供ができちゃったらまた新しい苦しみが増えるだけで
だから一般的には言いますけど
仏教ではあまり言わない
だからこのあんまりこの祝福文句
そういうふうな感じでしないんです
仏教の祝福文句っていうのは
まあ幸せでありますようにと
幸福でありますようにと
平安が訪れますようにと
あるいは逆にこの まあ災難とかね
病気とかね 悪いことはまあなんとかなくなりますようにというふうに
祝福もこうはもうたくさんありますけどね
あんまりこのないんですね
やっては社会の中で坊さんたちも生きてるんだから
いくらかは適当にはやってますけど
厳密にはない 昔 お釈迦様の時代ではね
阿羅漢たちはね もうおはようございます
こんにちはも言わないんです
それは当時ではそれをちゃんと知っていたんですね
やっぱり森林の人々ですから
嘘は言わないんだと いいお嫁さん見つかるようにと若い人に祝福したら
これはちょっとインチキなんですね
その若い人のこと 本当
本当に正直に慈しみの気持ちで分かっているんだったら
そんなことは言えないはずなんですね
で ストーリーがありますね
お釈迦様の息子がね すごい小さかったし
もう歳歳ぐらい まあちょうど歳なんですね
まあ年間も修行して 年間後で説法して
それから歳か歳ぐらいでしょうと思いますけどね
うちに戻ったのお釈迦様
うちに戻って 次の日 自分の前の奥さんが息子は父親見たことがないんですね
そこであなたの父親は
あのお坊さんたちの一番前に行く歩いているあのお釈迦様ですよと
今は家を出たんだけど
今は随分立派になっているんですよと
でも在家でいた時は随分財産持っていたんだと
で 結構それはなくなったんだと
なんかこの そのお釈迦様の徳でもうできた財産いくつかあって
それをお釈迦様はもう出家したらなくなったみたいです
それはもうあなたがどこにあるかとかね
どのようにすればその財産を得られるかとかね
あんた行ってお父さんだからね
聞いてみたらどうですかと
小さな子供をまあ送るんですね
お父さんに会って挨拶して話してみてくださいと
子供はずっと小さい時からお父さんがいないということを知っていましたし
出家して修行しているということも知っています
だから会いたくていたんです
だから何のことなく遠慮なしに行って
まあ大体誰でもお釈迦様の体を触ろうとはしないんですからね
まあ行って手を捕まって
で 何のことなくお父さんと呼んで
で 一緒に歩いていくんですね
言ったらお父さんに会いたかったんだと
で なんでですか？と聞いたら
お父さんいっぱい財産持ってるとね
お母さんが言いましたからね
で それを私ちょうだいと
あるところ行ってくださいと
お父さんは出家しているんだから
あれは要りませんということ
ああそうですか はい わかりました
何のことなく そのままお寺に連れて行ったんです
言って サーリプッタ尊者にこの子を出家させなさいと
でお釈迦様が言ったんです
まあ確かに私はすごい財産持っているんだと
それはあなたにあげるんだと
全部 言ったら子供大変喜んで
お父さん親切に全部あげてくれるんだなと思って行ったところで
この子を出家させなさい
で 出家させたんですね
すごい小さいなのに ですから
そこで解釈しているんですね
そんなくだらないお金やらああだこうだとかね
あげたっても それは不幸だけなんですね
せっかくの子供に限りない苦しみを与えることなんですね
ですから お釈迦様はこのアリーヤダナ
聖者の財産 本物の幸福を与えてあげると
これサッタアリーヤダナという七つの聖者の財産というものは経典で出ているんですね
まあそういうことで まあ解脱をすることしか幸福の道がないということで
出家させたんですね  それで小さいとき悟ったわけないんだけど
まあ一応お釈迦様は父親だからね
あまり側にいてもらわなかったんだけど
その代わりにサーリプッタ尊者に任せてあげて
面倒見てもらったんですね
で たまたま行って どうですかとか
元気ですかとかね で 様子を見る
それでラーフラという名前なんで
ラーフラ尊者も大変お釈迦様の仲間に入れてくれたんだからね
みんな一緒にいることを大変喜びを感じていてね
後で悟りましたけど 大変できた子だそうで
ですから この世の中で一番できている子っていうのはラーフラ尊者なんですね
いわゆるよく行儀よく
大人に対してね ちゃんと礼をしながら
物事をよく勉強して 言われる通りにちゃんと判断して行動できるということで
まあ立派な人ということで
まあ位まで上げてあるんです
そういうわけで 例えば若い人がね
まあ困ってるんだと 何ですかと
もう結婚の年にもなりましたけど
相手がないと じゃああなたに祝福してあげますと
というのは正直なところはできないんです
で 何人か私にも聞いたんですよ
同じ質問をね 私は答えたのはもうしょうがないんだけどね
あなたにとっては結婚いいものであるならば
あんたまあいろいろ仏教を勉強したり
いろんないいことやってるんだからね
結婚っていうのは あなたにとって素晴らしい
いいものであるならば
要は人生それで幸福になるならば
何のことの確実に相手が見つかりますよと
必死になって苦労して
欲だけで探しちゃうとね
かえって不幸になるかもしれませんだからね
そんなことは忘れてくださいと
で まあそこをまあ厳密な言葉答えなんですけどね
やっぱりまあ世俗的にでもね
結婚して幸福になる人はいるし
不幸になる人はいるし
すごい欲を持ってとにかく結婚するぞと思って結婚したってもうまくいかないしね
まあそのなるゆくでそういうことにもなりましたよという人々はうまくいっちゃうんですね
ですから あんまりそういうことにはあんまり真剣にならないのは仏教的な生き方
だから一応私はもう世界をきちんと 2つに分けてるんです
2回目で言ってるのは
純粋にまあお釈迦様の世界でお釈迦様の考え方で世の中を見たらどうすればいいかということなんですね
世俗的な部分はもう終わりましたからね
ですから 仏教的な立場で言うならば
そんなにもう金も借りたいとかね
頭の悪いのにすごい有名な実業家になりたいとかね
欲だけで頑張る必要はないんです
まあそこそこにほどほどに生きていれればよろしいし
そこでその人はね まあそれなりに正しい行動をするならば
自分にふさわしく人生はスムーズにうまくいくんです
そういうわけで まあそれなりに物事をね
日常生活の物事はまあそんな問題なくうまくいくんだからね
必死になって必死になって頑張れ
頑張れとかね ということも意味がないし
結婚する気持ちは全くないのに
もう周りからいじめられてやりなさい
それでわさわさ強引に考えてね
まあしたっても まあ幸福になるかどうかまたわからないしね
ですからまあそこら辺はまあほどほどで考えればいいんじゃないかなと
ですから 言えるのは頑張れ頑張れということはもう無意味ですと言われたら
何に頑張ればよろしいかとその人に聞けばいいんです
そうすると その人はなんとか言うでしょうし
それでわかりますね もっとしっかり金も頑張って収入は増やした方がよろしいかとかね
なんか言うでしょうね
それで収入増やしてどうなるんですかとまた聞けばよろしいし
今の収入ではいくらかはもうなんとか言って生きてますけど
そうすると収入が増えてあなたに車でも買えるでしょうと
それで何かいいことはありますか？と
毎日電車で通っているんだけど
会社にも車では行けないんだと
それで車買ったら駐車場も買わなくちゃいけないんだと
それで ものすごくたまにせっかく休みの日だったら車でね
ドライビングできますけど
その日に限ってみんな車出してるんだから動けないんですね
だから遊びたいところに目的地には届き
なんてますか 行けません
電車で行った方がいいんですね
だからね どうでしょうかというふうに合理的に物事を見られればよろしいんじゃないかな
ですから この俗世間で見れる
見られる もうこのあの頭に何か巻くでしょ
何巻っていうんですか
えっ たち？たちまき たちまきで巻いてね
必勝とか何とか書いてね
ああいうのは僕から見ればもうあんまり馬鹿馬鹿しいんですよ
まあ面白おかしくやってるんだったら別にもう通ったことないんだけどね
面白おかしく もうというならば別にもう我々も私も賛成しますけどね
楽しいんだったらね まあそれはすごい楽しいんだと
もうそれで必勝と思ってもすごい負けちゃったんだと
それでもまあ楽しくやったならば負けたそうとね
やっぱりどこかでこの野球なんか応援に行ってね
負けて帰っている場合
人々の顔なんか見るとなんか何かおかしいんですね
だから楽しみに行ったんだから
勝っても負けても楽しんで帰ってほしいんですね
せっかく野球を見に行ったならば
どうせ面白くないんだから
自分好きな野球 なんていうの？グループを応援しているんで
それもそこまではいいんだけど
そのグループがザンザン負けちゃっても
自分の楽しみを壊す必要ないんですね
落ち込む必要ないんです
ですから やっぱり楽しみにやるならばいいんですけどね
まあそういう風にこの徹底的に頑張ろうではないかとというのは意味がないんです
それはただの苦しみなんです
だから仏教からは苦しめというようなことはちょっと言いにくいんです
なぜならば 欲は苦しみを作るんです
欲があればあるほど苦しみということは事実なんです
希望があればあるほど
ものすごい精神的に さらに常にも不安なのに
ね 人生はね 前説明しましたから
大体どんな心も不安持ってます
悟らない限りは その上
希望やら夢やら よくああだこうだとか
余計なこと余計な妄想がね
いっぱい頭に叩き込んだところで
さらにさらに苦しくなって何もできなくなるんです
だからすごい苦しみなんです
ですから 仏教は自身のこと教えてますからね
それは言いにく 言えないんです
苦しめとは言えないんです
じゃあ逆に じゃあそれだったら頑張れということじゃなくて
まあ応援野球を応援したって負けちゃったら苦しいんだから
何もしないでいればどうですか
怠けたらどうですかと
何もしないんだと うつ病みたいな状態で何もしない
それだったらどうですかね
気持ちは この怠けること
また不思議なこと すごい苦しいんです
頑張れと言ったってもバカバカしくて
ただ苦しみが増えるだけなんです
頑張ること自体も苦しいし
結果としても苦しみしか得られないんですね
じゃあ何もしないで怠けちゃったらと言うたら
怠けることをまたすっごい苦しいんです
怠けて楽しいって人はいませんね
疲れたらまあ 1 日ぐらい休んだりするのは楽しいかもしれませんだけどね
1 日寝ているとかね それはもうずっと頑張ってきたんだから
1 日寝ることも大変楽しいんですけど
でも怠けることは大変苦しいんです
それであまりにもこの自信がなくて
行動できなくて 人々いるでしょうに
この 何といいますか 行動できないと
何か自信がないと すごい不安だと
すごい恐怖感があるんだという人々はいるでしょうね
社会の中で だから前の話で比べてみると
ああ それで結構やと言っても結構わけじゃないんで
その自信不安っていうのはちょっとノーマルじゃないんですね
私が前に説明したノーマルなどんな人間にもある不安なんです
それより以上にすごく自信がない
すごい不安 すごい恐怖感
神経質 何かやろうとするともう体が震えると
震えると そういう人々もいるんですけど
その人々の状態はどうですかというと
その人々は確実に自分の状態が悪いんだと
苦しいんだと 何とかしなくちゃいけないと思っているんです
ですから かえって頑張ることも仏教では認めてないんだけど
だからといって頑張れない人
行動できない人 怠けたがる人
その人々何を味わっているかというと
それまた苦しみを味わっているんです
私には自信が全くないと言って威張っている人がいますかね
威張れませんね すっごい辛くなるんです
自信がないと 神経質な人は私はものすごい神経質ですよと
ほんのちょっと音が違う音が入っただけでも
もうすごく神経にかかって
もうおかしくなりますよと言って威張るんですか？そんなことをって
誰も威張らないんです
それは悩みなんです なんとか治療法ないかと必死になって探してるんです
ですから 怠けることも苦しみです
[背景音楽]じゃあどうすればいいんですかね
頑張ってはいけませんし
欲が増えるんだから苦しみですし
怠けたらそれはそのまままた苦しみですし
そういうことはもうやっぱり我々いつでも言ってる
仏道っていうのは中道ということなんですね
中道というのはどっちにも関係ない
超越している立場なんです
これはどっちでもない
何か道があるはずなんです
ですから 頑張ってもいけないし
怠けてもいけない じゃあどうすればいいんですかと
どうすればいいんですか
今は純粋な仏教の世界で言うんです
どうすればいいんですかと
こういうこと 何かいいことをしようと頑張ってみればどうですかと
例えばもう怠けがあって
自信がない 神経質 すごい不安でもう怯えていると
そういうふうに病気な人がいるとする
精神的に ただ その人にとにかく何だかんだも頑張りなさいと言ったって意味がないんです
仕事でも勉強でも何でもいいんだから頑張りなさいと
意味がないんです 我々は何かそうじゃなくて
とにかく頑張れでもない
怠けることは善でもないんです
どっちでもよくない その代わりに仏教でいうのは
いいことを何か選んで決めてするにだ
いいことっていうのは善行為ですね
世の中で道徳的に素晴らしいと認めていること
こと ですから これは特別に
この私は今言っているのは
この心弱い人なんですね
この弱いと言ったっても
このちょっともう精神的に本当に弱い
もう普通の人よりも弱い
その普通の人よりも弱い
もう何も行動できない
自信がない人々は 余計な大胆なことをしなくてもいいんです
もともと自信ないんだから
神経質だから 車を運転でもまあ習いましょうとかね
そんなことやらない方がいいんです
神経質だったら で 何か難しい仕事にでもチャレンジしてみようとかね
やめた方がいいんです
ですから そういう人々は
自分が精神的に弱いし
神経質であるし 恐怖感で怯えているし
もうすごく弱い状態で
ですから その人にとって何かいいこと
善行為を考えて頑張ればいいんです
いいことをすることに頑張るんだと
別に欲のために頑張るんじゃなくて
善行為はいくらでもあるんです
それは決して収入を目指目指すと善行為じゃないんです
これで有名になろうと
偉くなろうと思ったら善行為じゃないんです
それは不善行為なんです
ですから すごく献身的で
何かいいことをしますと
ですから 私は言いたいのは
たとえ小さい行為 行動でもいいんです
何かいいことをしてみたらどうですかと
そうすると その心の問題
心の病気は治るんです
いいことをしたら そこで自分一人で自信がないんだから
自分一人で行動できないとという状態
もともとあるでしょうね
それだったら人に隠れてでも
例えば素晴らしいいい行為をしている
何か組織とかなんとかグループとかあるんだと
ある場合はそちらに行って
隠れてでもほんのちょびっとちょびっとだけでもいいことしてあげると
例えば自信がある人々は自信なんかあったらもう行ってボランティアやってるでしょうに
自信はない 何も行動できない人もいるんだ
いるならばその人行って
もう大胆な行動はその人にできないかもしれませんだけど
一応荷物運んであげるぐらいでもね
避難避難している人々のいるところ
ちょっと掃除してあげるぐらいでもできるんです
ですから 小さくても構いません
自分一人で出て行って
大胆にもじゃあ私がこういうこういうことをしますよということはできないかもしれません
自信ないんだから もともと
だから隠れてでもいいんです
いいことをしてみると
これはものすごい違うんです
心の回転が その時はもう奇跡的に心が変わるんです
あちこち公園なんか行ったところでね
まあかなり散らかしたりしているんだから
一応そこら辺ちょっとゴミでも拾ってもゴミ箱に入れてるぐらいでも
自分が食べた弁当だから
それはゴミ箱に入れるのは何のいいことでもなんでもないんだよ
そんなことは そうじゃなくて
そこら辺散らかしてみたら
まあ何のことなく拾ってゴミ箱に入れると
それでどうしてもあるでしょうに
ゴミを分けているんだけど
結構分けてないんです
平気で捨てる それを見たら自分でちょっと分けてあげる
ただのゴミ箱かもしれません
そんなことをやってみたら
あの心の病気は治ります
その心の弱気をなくすというのは
すごくそういうことで簡単にできるんです
そちらには心の法則があるんです
だから 何の利益も考えてないんです
何の利益も考えてないんだから
そちらによくできた よくできなかったという言葉出てこないんです
例えば 公園のゴミを拾ってゴミ箱に入れたらよくできましたっていうこともないし
よくできなかったということ
成り立たないでしょうに
例えば その人を仕事に雇ったならば
あんた公園 公園をちゃんと掃除しなさいと
そうすると よくできたかないかということは問題が出てくるんです
自分でただいい行動をしようと
何か清らかな行動をしようと思って
もういくらかのところだけ綺麗にしたならば
それぐらいでも結構でしょうし
よくできた よくできなかったっていうことじゃないんですね
ここら辺は掃除できましたということで終わるんです
ですから そこで不思議な働きなんです
成功か成功でないかという概念は乗り越えているんです
よくできた よくできなかったっていうことはないんです
で 収入でやっちゃうといい加減にしたらごまかしでしょうし
あるいは収入が入るんだから一生懸命やろうと思ったら欲であるし
そこはあまりうまくいかない
それで性格は治らないんです
例えば あなたに給料を 1 日これぐらいあげますから
公園掃除しなさいって言ったら
これぐらいもらうんだったらしっかり掃除しましょうと思う人が
やっぱりそこで欲が働いてるんです
まあそれぐらいのまあ低給だから
まあ時給というんですか
時給まあ給料まあまあ
そこまあそこそこにやるぞと思ってやったら
それはごまかしであるし
ですから そこで性格は治りません
どっちでも真面目に仕事をしても
いい加減に仕事をしても
ですから 心を直したければ善行為をすること
それそれはもう大変 もうすごい効率高い結果なんです
いいことをすれば まあそれぐらいでやって
どんな働きかというと
何もこの収入も何も考えてなくて
ただ行為だけしている
その人が それでその人が行動の秘密わかるんです
僕 前ずっと説明したこと
結果とかなんとかとかじゃなくて
その時その時やることだけ考えてやればよろしいということ
あ これすごい気持ちいいと
何かすることは気持ちいいと
その人はわかるんです
それでやったことはどうせいいことだから
本人がいいことをできたと
中途半端でしたかもしれませんだけど
中途半端でもいいことをできたという
自分には充実が生まれるんです
それであの自信ないとか
なんと暗いとか 行動できないということがすぐ飛んで消えちゃうんです
それから もしいいことをしたならば
人々が見たら褒めるでしょうに
素晴らしい人だと それはものすごい良いことでね
社会にいい人だと認めてくれちゃったら
何の自信？それで消えてしまっちゃうんです
ただそれだけで それで口で褒めなくても
いいことをする人々に対しては社会の態度が違うんです
本当にこの正直な気持ちで
利益を利益を考えないでいいことをすると
みんな何か素晴らしい人だなとかね
できてる人やと すぐ心に波動が生まれるんです
ですから その人にとってはその人間の間でいることは何のこともないんです
みんな優しい気持ちは自然に生まれてるんです
周りの人々はね ですから
もともと自信なかったかもしれませんだけど
やってみるとやれるもんだと
この人には自信がついてきます
ですから 我々はもうとにかくいいことをしようと頑張れば
なんとか人生は正しい方向には行くんです
それで怠けについてちょっと喋ります
仏教は怠けはものすごく嫌いです
あれすっごい苦しみなんです
怠けで楽しいという人はないんです
行動して楽しいんです
ですから すっごい苦しみなんです
で いろんなわけで仏教は怠けを嫌い
で お釈迦様の時代で 6人の開祖様がいたんです
宗教を教えた人々 この六人もろくでもない教えを教えていたんだけど
まあしょうがないんですけど
その中で一人がすっごい危ないんですね
その人はこの定受論という教え
定っていうのは常に 受っていうのは常にあるという
パーリ語でニヤタワーダというわけです
ニヤタワーダというのは
大体日本語に訳すると
まあ決定的定め論か定受論かどっちかなんですね
決定的定め論 この人の名前は真っ赤に交差されてるわけです
あの これ作り話じゃなくて歴史的にいた人なんです
仏教でないテキストでもその人の名前が出ています
この人というのは 人間の生命すべて
宇宙すべてのことはきちんと定めているんだと
厳密にプログラム済みだと
ですから余計なことをするなということなんです
わかりやすく言えば で
こういうこと 例えば人が金持ちになるというならば
その金持ちになることをその人にとってはプログラムされているんですね
ですから 自然にその人はそうなるんです
もしある人はすっごい貧しく生まれたならば
別に困らなくてもいいんです
そういうプログラムだから
貧しくてそれで結構やと
もし低いカーストで生まれたら
その風にプログラムしているんだと
それで彼が計算するんですね
一人一人のプログラムは平等ですと
平等ということは この輪廻まで考えているんですね
人は何回王様になるか
何回大臣になるか 何回金持ちになるか
何回乞食になるかとか
そういうのは全部もう回数は決まってるんだと
彼が回数まで言ってるんです
一人の生命がこれぐらい回数は王で生まれるんだと
これぐらい回数はもう大臣で生まれるとかね
これぐらい回数は農民で生まれると
これぐらいの生まれ変わりは商人で商売やってる人になるんだとか
それだったら全部同じだから同じですね
だから今貧しい人が別に困ることねえんです
回数決まってるんだから
そこで彼言うのは 出家者も出家になる回数もまた決まってるんだと
それでもし人が出家して
私は修行して心を清らかにして
それで解脱を得ようとするならば
あんなものはもうもう無意味ですよと
何の意味もないんだと
この自分の回数終わったら
糸を巻いた糸を離してあげたら
糸があるところまで行ってそこで止まるような感じで
自分の回数終わったら
愚か者も賢者もみんな輪廻を終えて解脱するんだと言って
すごい面白い教えなんですね
まあまあ今今の時代で言ったらみんな大変人気が出るだろうと思います
もう焦らなくてもいいやと
焦るなと そのままでいいと
そこでさらに厳密に言うんです
たとえ自分が何か殺人をしたと
まあ気にしてもいいんですと
回数決まってるんだと
何回人殺し屋になるか
何回泥棒になるか その人の輪廻転生でもう決まってるんだと
だからその自分の順番当番回ってただわけで
その当番回ったんだから
その人は人殺しなくちゃいけない
当番回した人を回された人が
それで誰が決めたかということについてははっきりしない
彼にとっては誰でも神様でも運命でも何でもいいのです
概念は それただの概念
彼にとってはこの絶対的神という概念も彼が作ってるんです
いくつかの概念彼が言ってるんです
どっちでもいいんです
運命で定めてる 神様にプログラムされてると
それはどうでもいいんです
そんなことは とにかくきちんと平等にピッとしと計算されてると
なんかすごい楽しい教えですね
何もしなくていいんだから
お釈迦様はこのいろんな宗教は批判しましたけど
非難していないんです
お釈迦様とんでもないと非難したのはその人なんです
とんでもないと 他の人々の教えは批判する
でも非難はしない だからバラモン教に対していろんな批判はあるんだけど
バラモン人は誰もお釈迦様のことを悪く思わなかったんですね
よく批判して批判してくれるんだと
だから 何か分からないことがあったらお釈迦様に聞きましょうというぐらい
もうすごい親しみを感じるんですね
素晴らしい批判だから
でも この人を非難している
どのように非難非難しているかというと
小さな小川に大きな網をかけているような感じで
小さな川だから大きな網をかけちゃったら
全部魚が全部生き物があれにはめられて死んじゃうんだと
そのようにこの人は聞く聞く人はみんな確実に地獄に引っ張るようにすごいことを言ってる
だからすごい人気になるんでしょう
特に現代の人々に教えてあげたいぐらい
もう爆発的に人気出るだろうと思います
今のこの神の考え方とは随分違いますからね
しっかりと合理的なんです
神はプログラムしたんだから
厳密にプログラムしているんだと
そこでインドで一般的な輪廻転生の概念もありましたから
ですから 身体障害で生まれたって
まあまあいいですよ もう落ち着きなさいと
焦るなと 今私はすごい体力があるとしたっても
私も決まってる回数がそんな状態にならなくちゃいけないんだと
すごい金持ちと全く 1円もない貧乏なまあまあいいわ
それで今あなたは貧乏ですけど
あなたは今貧乏の役目を回してる
回されてるだけ この人は大金持ちになる役を回されてるだけと
それでなんかみんな落ち着くんです
でもすっごいもうとんでもない人やっていうのは
お釈迦様のもう まあそれも非難とは言いませんだけど
お釈迦様はやっぱりはっきりと間違ってるんだと
そのお釈迦様が言うのは
自分の意思で歩きながら
自分の意思でご飯食べながら
自分の意思で体を洗ったり
いろんなことしたりしながら
その人 人の行為を否定しているんだと
何もしなくてもいいと言ったって言っても
人はいろんなことをしているんだから
じゃあ何もしないでいたらどうなるんですか？と明確にわかることでしょうね
具体的に見れば ですから
その人は因果法則を否定するんですね
因縁によって結果が現れますよということは徹底的に否定しているんです
ですから 常住論でもありまして
徹底的に怠け論でもあります
それにもそれはものすごい邪見だと
仏教はものすごく努力することを励むこと
すごく勧めているんです
頑張るべきですよ 努力するべきですよ
でも間違わないでください
頑張れ 頑張れじゃないんです
何に頑張るべきか 何に努力するべきかということだけはきちんと定義するんです
それは人の心は常に弱い
人の心は常に汚れている
心を清らかにすることに頑張れと
心の洗濯をするために頑張れと
金儲かるために頑張るではないんです
ですから 仏教では必死になって頑張れと言っているんです
でも目的決まっている
心を洗濯するために必死になりなさい
1 分も怠ってはいけません
ですから 仏教の人々は因縁論を因果法則をよく理解して努力するんです
その努力はまたずっと説明していた努力と同じことなんですね
いわゆる行動によって結果が得られるんですね
悪い行動は悪い結果といい行動はいい結果はしているんです
それで行動だけじゃないんです
気持ちも利くんです 例えば褒めてほしくて
認めてほしくて 人にお金あげたり助けたりしたっても幸福にならないかもしれません
なぜならば気持ちが汚れてるんだからもうすぐバレちゃいますし
みんなそのそのことを批判するし
ですから この因縁によって結果が出てくる
いいことをしたらいい結果が出ますけど
そこは間違って考えちゃいけないんです
ただ人を助けたんだからといって
その人にいい結果が出るわけじゃないんです
なぜかというと その人は人を助けたのはどんな気持ちで助けたんですかと
それは全く営利目的でなく
単なる善行として公園のゴミを拾うような感じで
全く営利目的なし 全く人がそれで助けられればそれだけで十分という
ただ私は何か行動したい
私には行動できて それで十分だと
なんかできました ああ
それで結構やと人を助けることができました
ああ それでもう満足だと
その代わりになんとかと思っちゃうと
もう汚れているんですね
私は人を助けたんだから
村のこの地方の人々をみんな助けてあげたんだから
悲しい時 地震が来る時は起きた時は私は片っ端から家一軒一軒行って訪ねてどうですかと全部調べたんだと
だから私に投票してくださいと言うと
それは汚れてるんですね
そこでそういう人は選挙に出たところで負けたとするともう怒るんでしょうし
もう全く恩知らない人間ではないかと
私はここまで人々のために尽力やったのに
なんで私は選挙で負けたんですかとかいう風になる可能性はあります
そういうのは善行為じゃないんです
見た目は善行為で見えますけど
本来は善行為じゃない
汚れてる行為なんですね
ですから 因縁法則をよく理解して
純粋な善行為をすると
素晴らしく人生はいい方向へ変わっちゃうんです
ですから 仏教は結局は頑張れと言ってるんです
でも無茶頑張れということではないんです
何でもいいんだから頑張れってことじゃないんです
ただ いいことをするために頑張れと
その時も まあそれよりももっと厳密に言うのは
心を洗濯するために 心を洗うために
心の汚さをなくすために
必死になって頑張ってくださいと
だから 名誉のためにいいことをしちゃったら
結局心を汚してるでしょうに
そんなものは認めない
いい結果を目指して人を助けちゃったら
それは汚れてるんです
それは認めない まあ逆に言えば
もういい結果目指せてもいいことをしなさいとも言いますけど
とにかくそれはもう大体普通の論理的な考え方ですけど
厳密にはそれを認めない
自分が慈悲の瞑想をしているんだからといって
みんな自分のことを親切にやってくれると思っちゃったらとんでもないんです
そんなものは慈悲の瞑想じゃないんです
結果考えちゃったらもう汚れてるんです
ですから ただ慈しみの心を作ると
それで十分だと どんな人を見ても
自分のは自分の兄弟のように
親戚のように感じるんだと
人の気持ちがずっと自分の心に映るんだと
悲しがっているか 楽しがっているかどうかだとか
それだけで十分です ですから
そういうふうなことに必死になって頑張ってほしいんですね
そこは因果法則によりますと
純粋な清らかな行為は純粋に清らかな結果を出す
汚れている行為は汚れている結果を出す
中途半端な行為はやってるのはやってることはいいんだけど
やっぱり心の中が汚れてると中途半端なんですね
だから社会の人には批判することもできないし
褒めることもできないし
別に悪いことやってるわけじゃないんだけど
どこかで考え方がおかしいと
そういう風な中途半端な行動をやってる人は中途半端な結果を得られると
そこで因果法則を理解して徹底的に努力することは
本当は仏教で徹底的に認めているんです
そこで修行というものも心清らかにする道なんですね
心を洗濯する道なんですね
ですから 修行については仏教はすごい厳しいんです
じゃあこれからの出家者にお釈迦様がおっしゃっていることを言いますけど
出家している人々に我々にどれぐらい必死になりなさいと言うかというと
あなたの服に火がついたと思えと
あなたの髪の毛に火がついていると思えと
自分の服に髪に火がついている人がどれぐらい必死で火を消そうとするかと
それよりも必死になって修行に励めと
理由は 瞬間瞬間人は変化していく
どんな瞬間で死ぬかとわかってはないんです
だから怠ける暇がないんです
来年修行すると 今出家して若いんだから
今はちょっと勉強して
それからもう説法でもして
まあいくらかもう行動して
年取ったところで修行するとかね
そんな怠ける暇はないんだと
いつ死ぬかわからないんだと
だから死ぬ前にやっておかなくちゃいけないことは
心を完璧に清らかにすること
他のものは後でいつでも生きているならばできるんです
結婚することも 会社作ることも
生きてるならばもうできるんですけど
死ぬ前にこれはしておかなくちゃいけない
それでお釈迦様厳密に言うのは
死ぬ時は後悔しないようにと
そういうのも出家に言ってるんです
だからお釈迦様の弟子たちだから
すごい厳しく言うんです
一般の方々に言ってるわけじゃないんですけど
死ぬ前に後悔しないように
ですから 死ぬ瞬間になったところで
全然仏教では慰めてあげない
死ぬ時に死ぬ間際になったら
お坊さんたちが他のお坊さんの昔な今はどうか分かりませんだけどね
お見舞いに行ったら聞くのは
あんたはもうそろそろ死にかけてるんだ
もうそろそろ死ぬんだと
じゃあどう何か得たんですかと
何かもう人間の智慧を乗り越えている
わずかなことでも何か智慧を得たんですかと
それ聞きなさいということなの
そう聞かれたら 別に何もないと言ったら
まあそれはすごい恥なんです
ただ動物みたいに生きた
ご飯食って年取って生きていただけなんです
何も得てないんです お金いくら儲けたっても置いておくものだから
自分のものじゃないんです
会社 100個ぐらい作ったっても
死ぬ時は自分のものじゃないんだから他人のものだから
だから自分のものになるものを何か死ぬ時は持ってないと
あの人生は無意味なんです
ですから いつ死ぬかわからないんだから
死ぬもう必死になって
この心を清らかにして
何か超越した智慧を得るために努力することには随分厳しく徹底的に言ってるんです
それはもう厳密に言ってるんです
それから心を清らかにすること
心を洗濯すること あるいは心の煩悩を完全に無くすことこそが生命の目的なんです
何のためにも生きてるわけじゃないんだけど
せっかく生きているんだから輪廻転生しているんだから
なんか目的を作らなくちゃいけないんです
それで仏教というのは心を完全に清らかにするそう
完全に解脱を得るんだと
心の汚れは全部取り除くんだと
それは生きる目的だと目的を作るんです
それは経典では明確なんです
ヴィラーガッターエニッバーナッターエパッバジャンと
欲をなくすために 涅槃を体験するために出家するんだと
だから出家っていうのは
全部財産も兄弟も親戚もみんな捨てていくんだから捨ててもいいんだと
財産も名誉も何でも なぜならばそんなものは生きる目的じゃないんです
生きる目的は解脱することだから
解脱するためにはもうとにかくもうそういう高い目的を作って頑張ってほしいと
その場合は死ぬことは恐れるなと
死ぬことも恐れずに頑張れというのは
仏教では解脱することだけ
でも世の中で金儲けることに言うんです
死にことを恐れないでやりなさいと
あまりにも汚い それより生きることが大事ですからね
バカバカらしいんです
ですから 死ぬことも恐れないで
死んでもいいんだから頑張るぞというならば
心を洗濯することに頑張った方がいいんです
今日は寒いんだから瞑想できないと
もう今頃は暑いんだから瞑想できないとかね
ああだこうだ そんな言い訳は聞くわけじゃない
死んでも死んでもいいんだからやりなさいというぐらい厳しいんです
修行者には 出家する人々には
お釈迦様の戒めというのは
それを聞いて昔の昔話なんですけど
昔のお釈迦様より前なんですけど
他のカッサパというお釈迦様ブッダがいた時は
そのブッダの教えがみんな怠け連中で
お釈迦様亡くなって間もないうちにもうだいたいみんな仏教を忘れしまっちゃったんです
それである 5  6人のお坊さんたちがグループが
これはけしからんと こんな尊い教えはね
みんなあまり真面目に修行しようとしないんだと
だからみんなと一緒にいると
我々も汚れてまた輪廻転生するんだと思って
もうはしごを作って崖に登るんです
なかなか人はもう登れないところに
すごい高い崖に もうどんどんゆっくりゆっくりいろいろはしごを作って作って登って
降り登って あの梯子を捨てちゃったんです
もう降りないんです そこで決めたんです
我々は死ぬまで修行しますと
この崖から降りませんんだから
もし瞑想して悟って神通力やら超能力やら得たならば
まあ空を飛んで出てもいいんだと
そうでなかったらここで死ぬんだと
それでもやるということで決めて
まあ修行を始めたそうですね
それで一人は一日で悟りました
もう死に覚悟でやりましたから
悟った人がさっと空を飛んで出て行っちゃったんです
行って托鉢してみんなの食べる分を持ってきたんです
持ってきて あの まあどうぞ
私にはやることないんだからね
托鉢してきますから 皆様方は召し上がって頑張ってくださいと言ったら
そのお坊さんたちがとんでもない
そんな約束はしなかったと
そんな約束はなかったと
ですから あなたは悟ったことは大変ありがたいと
あんたはもう帰ってくださいと
我々も自分たちで頑張ると言って
まあ 2日目 3日目 一人一人まあ悟ったり
不還果になったり一来果になったり
もう最後に二人残って
一人が一来果って第 1番目の位時に悟ったんですね
もう 1週間  2週間時間経ってるんです
そこで一来果になった人は
まあそんな神通力あるわけじゃない
そこで死んじゃったんだけど
一人が何もなかったんです
一生懸命瞑想したんだけど
何もなくてそこで死んじゃったんです
死んでも悪いことしたわけじゃないんだから
命かけて修行してたんだからね
それによって疲れが梵天に生まれたんだけどね
その人なんです 仏教でお釈迦様にそこで輪廻転生して会ったのは
会って 1分以内で悟ったの
会って話してすぐ悟ったと
すごい有名な話で 立ったまんまで説法を聞いて何か言ってくださいと言ったら
まあその人の過去の癖があったんで
お釈迦様托鉢に出ていたんです
遠くから来たんです この人
話を聞こう 説法を聞こうと
遠くからもう何ヶ月かもかけてきたのに
お釈迦様出ているんで
そこで追っていったんですね
どこら辺托鉢に行ったんですか？とお坊さんたちやめたんで止めたんで
もうもういいですよと
別に帰りますからとお釈迦様
いえ 待てませんと あとは道路でお釈迦様に出会う
出会ったらお釈迦様にあいさつして
お願いしますから 私に解脱の道を教えてくださいと言ったら
お釈迦様冗談じゃない
今は托鉢すると行くところだから
後で言いますよと いえいえ
私に今おっしゃってくださいと
お釈迦様断る で  3回目お釈迦様断る
まあ托鉢する時は托鉢ですよと
説法しませんと  3回目も断ったら
この人言うのはご飯はいつでも生きているならば食えるんだと
生きているんだったら
そんなに大事ですかと
食べることは でも人はいつ死ぬかということはわからないんだと
だから食べるより私に説法することを先決で大事ですよとお釈迦様に説法したんです
托鉢より お釈迦様も負けたんです
なんのことなど まあそれはその通りですということで
はい わかりましたと 立ったまんまで
ほんのちょっとの 1行
2  3行ぐらいの これは解脱の道ですよという道を教えたんです
そのまんま完全に悟ったんです
ですから この そういう心洗濯するために頑張ったら
それだけは残るんです
通帳でもうゼロはもう 8個
9個  10個あったっても残らない
そんな死ぬ時は 持っていけませんから
まあ冗談で言いますけどね
死んで閻魔様に会ったところで
自分の通帳のコピーでも見せてみてください
天国に連れて行くかどうかね
天国なんか宇宙船でもみたいに乗っていくものだったらお金でいけますけど
役に立たないそんなもの
ですから このいいことをするためには
必死になって頑張ってくださいと
もう一人のお坊さんが自殺したんです
それお釈迦様の時で あの
何でしたっけ 名前は ゴウディカというお坊さんなんですけど
で どうも内気な幼坊さんで
必死になって瞑想したら
このなんとなく禅定状態みたいな状態に来るんですが
すぐもう心混乱して乱れて壊れちゃうんです
また苦労して苦労して禅定状態のところに来るんだけど
また壊れてしまっちゃうし
性格なんでどこでも何年も頑張るんです
そこでもものすごい怒ったんです
自分のことに なんて情けない人間ですか
自分が せっかくブッダのところに出家していて
こんなにも素晴らしい教えがあって
自分の心の情けないところ
弱いところにすごく怒ったんです
だから決めたんです 私にはおそらく悟れないかもしれません
頭が悪いんだから それでも禅定ぐらいは作って
盆提寺でも生まれたら
その波動で反応で 後ででも悟れるんだと
地獄なんかに落ちちゃったら
もう人間界なんかに行っちゃったら
どこに生まれ変わるかわからない
そうすると修行もできないということで
今度やるぞと思ってカミソリを持って
まあ人がいないところに行ったんです
だいたいこのお坊さんはもう瞑想してもすぐ禅定壊れるということをもうだいたいみんな知ってるし
噂はお釈迦様の耳にも入ったんです
あの人 カミソリを持って山に入ったんだから
随分神経質な人だからちょっとわからないということが
お釈迦様は何のことなく黙っていたんです
やめさせなさいとかね
全然ない そこでそのお坊さんがもうまず瞑想する
首を切るつもりなんです
瞑想して これでダメだと言って首を切りながら瞑想に入ったんです
そうするともっと必死になりますから
そこでも首を切って でもすぐ死にませんだからね
まあこれで終わる人生はと思って
自分が今までどんな風な生活してきたんですかと観察していたら
もう完璧に修行はしてきました
ですから後悔することはない
今ももう悟れないんだから
もう首を切っただけであって
別に後悔する必要はない
ちゃんと覚悟を決めてやったことだから
それで死ぬ時のその状態
痛みとかね それを観察し始めたら
完全に阿羅漢位まで悟ったんです
悟ったと同時に死んでしまったんですけど
そこでマーラという神がいて
仏教に邪魔する神がいて
もうなんかこの人のこのやる気満々の状態にはちょっと驚いちゃったんですね
このこの神っていうのは
なかなかこの人は修行するのは嫌なんです
ですから 修行する人には邪魔が多いし
怠ける人にはもうすごい名誉やら財産やらもういろんないっぱい用意し
汚れば汚るほど成功する
世俗的には清らかになればなるほど
世俗的には批判されるということもありますね
そこでこのマーラという神がこれに邪魔しようと思ってお釈迦様に報告するんだそうです
あんた知ってますか？あなたの弟子一人が自殺を図ろうとしているんだと
それは仏教にとってはとんでもない恥だと
仏教に入って もう心を清らかにする世界に入って
精神的にね 落ち込まれて自殺したということは
もう仏教にとってはものすごい不名誉なことだからやめさせてくださいと言ったら
お釈迦様が仏教のことはあなた心配しなくてもいいのですと追い出しちゃったんです
そこでそのお坊さんが自殺して亡くなりましたし
悟ったし それでお釈迦様は随分亡くなったらみんなと一緒にそこへ行って
その遺体ですか それを持って全て持ってきて
すごい大きな葬式までやって
お釈迦様 この人こそ素晴らしい私の教えを守った素晴らしい人だと褒めてあげたんです
悟りましたから ですから
悟ることだったら 死ぬことでも惜しむなということは仏教の道教えなんですね
もう頑張れということなんですね
その場合は  どうしますかね
時間はだいたいそろそろ終わってはいますけど
まだまあたくさんの半分ぐらいはもう半分が残りますけど
そういうわけで 結論として言えるのは
なんかむちゃくちゃ頑張れではなくて
いいことをすることには頑張らなくちゃいけない
なかなかいいことをしにくいんです
いいことはしにくいんです
そういうわけで この本当に努力して
何でもいいんだから いいことをすることに頑張ると
修行する場合は 一番最高な人生の生きる目的というのは解脱すること
それ以上の目的はない
それだったら死ぬことを恐れずに努力すればいいのです
ですから 何度かんでも努力するということは
仏教ではあまり意味がないということで話を終了させていただきます
で  [終始背景音楽]